ce sont des images qui renvoie
inlassablement au 7 janvier 2015
le même cauchemar qui seront produits à
quelques mètres des lieux de la tuerie
da la vie à 12 personnes dont huit
membres de la rédaction de charlie hebdo
c'est donc vendredi un peu avant midi
qu'un homme surgit muni d'un hachoir
il attaque de collaborateurs de la
société de production première ligne
alors en pause cigarette et dont le
pronostic vital n'est plus engagé
rapidement les services de police sont
mobilisées bouclant le périmètre et
confinant les établissements scolaires
des événements qui oblige le premier
ministre jean castex alors en visite en
seine-saint-denis à revenir en urgence
dans la capitale un événement grave
vient de se produire à paris une attaque
par arme blanche a été perpétré dans le
11e arrondissement devant l'ancien siège
de charlie hebdo et dans ces conditions
je suis obligé de me rendre au centre de
crise à beauvau pour m'assurer de la
réalité de la situation et de son
évolution
dès le début le lieu et la temporalité
de l'attak poussent les enquêteurs à
privilégier l'hypothèse d'une attaque
jihadiste
cet acte présumé terroriste se déroule
en effet en plein procès des attentats
du 7 janvier 2015 et trois semaines
après la republication des caricatures
de mahomet par l'hebdomadaire satirique
le parquet national anti terroriste se
saisit de la sphère nous avons décidé de
nous
du chef de tentative d'assassinât en
relation avec une entreprise terroriste
ainsi que pour association de
malfaiteurs terroristes
le critt de nature krine l'auteur
présumé de l'attaqué et lui rapidement
interpellés à proximité de la place de
la bastille il s'agit selon les
dernières informations d'un pakistanais
dont 18 ans déjà connu des services de
police notamment pour port d'armes
illégal selon des sources proches des
enquêtes
l'assaillant aurait assumé un geste
politique et visaient bien charlie hebdo
dont la rédaction a déménagé depuis des
années dans un lieu tenu secret ce qui
n'a pas empêché le traumatisme de
ressurgir ce vendredi